here's a fun question from a UK maths  competition dots in the lattice are  evenly spaced by one unit vertically and  horizontally calculate the Shaded area  there are many ways to solve this  problem I will present one method we  will calculate the area of half the  region which is this green triangle  rotate this triangle 180 degrees from  its topmost vertex and then scale it  down to form this purple triangle the  green triangle is similar to the purple  triangle the green triangle's base is 5  and the purple triangle's base is three  their combined Heights are equal to two  and that means the Green triangle's  height is 5 8 of 2.  we can then calculate the area of the  green triangle is one half its base  times its height which will be equal to  25 over 8. we want two times the green  triangle so twice this area will be  equal to 25 over 4 which is equal to the  answer of 6.25